thank you
[Music]
so eight years ago a meteor believed to
have been two feet long entered the
Earth's atmosphere
and more than 100 000 miles an hour
before exploding into tiny hot fragments
oh thank God and falling into the South
Pacific Ocean good good some scientists
believe it came from another star system
which would make it the first known
Interstellar object of its size to
impact Earth that we know of whoa and a
professor at the Harvard Smithsonian
Center for astrophysics is planning an
expedition to retrieve fragments of the
meteor from the ocean floor and by
analyzing the debris he's hoping to
determine its Origins even going so far
as to make the extraordinary suggestion
that it could be a technological object
created by alien life whoa oh my God
here we go alien crash here we go well a
meteor we don't know what it is but he
says because of extra of interstellar
origin could be anything and and some
astronomers are saying like we don't
have any data on this so why are you why
are you saying that like you're just
conjecturing
um and some people are basically saying
like hey dude aren't you just like
trying to use this to drive more funding
for your like project get more attention
for your project do it yeah right
um but he's saying it moved very fast
roughly 40 kilometers per second when
it's when it exploded in the lower
atmosphere and from that we can infer
that was moving far too fast to be bound
to the sun right so the Sun's gravity
having slingshoted around that's why
they think it's Interstellar that's why
he well yeah exactly but that but it was
the the rate of speed that was moving at
he thought that it's too fast it's just
too fast to to just have been bound to
the sun right so so that means it's it's
of interstellar origin and then he's
saying that the well he submitted a
paper
um making that case to appear reviewed
astronomy journal and that paper got
rejected because the data was incomplete
some of the data relied on observations
from classified missile detection
systems making their estimates of the
object's velocity impossible for
reviewers to verify but
there was a memo published by the U.S
space command and it confirmed that the
object came from another star system
so there's kind of two thoughts on this
I'm actually amazed that we've never
like nothing slammed into us that big
yeah because we're in a solar system
right and then we're like but we're
actually flying through the air like the
Earth and the Sun and the entire solar
system is flying through there through
all this [ __ ] like space debris and
asteroids and all that [ __ ] and as we're
like plummeting through the air it's
crazy how nothing has ever just come
flying from another Direction and just
destroying the last time it's it's it's
it's hit us a couple of times the last
one that hit us
um they they attribute the extinct to
dinosaurs because there's a huge [ __ ]
Crater of Mexico
are off the Gulf of Mexico yeah so the
you know that Texas curve right there
that they say that's actually a crater
and then there was a meteor that hit
that and
um it caused like the whole [ __ ]
world to like rupture yeah and then so
it blacked out the Sun for like hella
days with the ashes and that's what
killed off all the dinosaurs and all
that stuff because there's they observe
like in uh geologists would see like a
layer of Ash and like not nuclear
material but volcanic material some [ __ ]
like that all across the globe
at a certain period And then after that
you don't see that many dinosaur bones
and you start to see like other stuff so
so and then there's they're saying that
there's been multiple times of that in
the past that has shaped the world and
like extinct certain things
so that wasn't the first mass extinction
it's just the recent one I see yeah
because jubia Jupiter protects Earth
actually from a lot of the debris
because it's like rotating around here
it's so huge it's so big that it just it
takes all all of it and actually
protects Earth and a lot of other
planets Kepler
um
what was it the um the three meteors
that hit Jupiter in like the 90s oh yeah
was was
projected to maybe hit Earth or be in a
problem for Earth it had it not hit
Jupiter then wow yes which we actually
saw it live which was crazy and also
Jupiter guys go to Jupiter to get more
stupider
yeah no but girls go to Venus to get
some penis and so but Jupiter's always
been that thing you know it's like it's
it's a it's a pretty big block oh yeah
it's the o-line pretty much yeah the Jew
Jupiter acts as the o-line yeah
what about Saturn what the [ __ ] Saturn
Saturn's just a different looks yeah
it's just different look got the fancy
ring huh yeah did you guys ever have
like a favorite planet growing up what
were top three favorite planets I just
like Uranus was my shirt I just like
Uranus for obvious reasons hey what are
those reasons Bart right well like Pluto
Pluto Pluto was one of my favorites but
yeah Pluto was Planet not planet planet
no I think they're saying it's a planet
I think so I don't know who gives a [ __ ]
it rotates with us so I don't know like
you know they can't make up their minds
yeah you know I saw the Milky Way when I
was in Hawaii you could actually see the
get the [ __ ] out that was pretty [ __ ]
cool what do you see like you is it like
foggy what do you see no so we went up
to Mauna Kea which is like the highest
point on the big island and it's like 14
000 uh elevation yeah and we did some
stargazing and [ __ ] you have to like go
at like 4am or something we went at like
7 P.M well we went there like six and we
saw all the cool Hubble Telescope not
tubble but all the cool telescopes that
like uh Caltech has you know up on the
Summits and then once it hit Nightfall
we could just see all the constellations
you see [ __ ] everything and they were
just kind of pointing out what like um
random or it looks organized in what you
see it looks it looks random but then
when they have these really cool laser
pointers they show you exactly what like
the constellations are so like the Libra
the Capricorn all that [ __ ] and you
could see all of it and then depending
on the months so you could see all the
whatever signs are and the later in the
year you could see those way better but
you can't see all the the birth months
that like have passed already so I don't
know what those are I kind of spaced out
but you could see [ __ ] the Milky Way
galaxy like that [ __ ] was crazy dude
well that's where we are dude that's
what I mean well you could like yeah you
could see it and like uh I've never been
able to see that ever in my life and we
saw [ __ ] Saturday my own [ __ ] is
it because there was no light pollution
no light pollution you're all the way up
oh bro it's like it's like uh it was it
felt like I was looking at a photograph
from the NASA website is that on Kauai
that was on the big Islands so I don't
need to go to Kauai ever then no just go
to the big island you know Kauai sounds
like [ __ ] to me yeah I know Nikki always
was like we gotta go to quiet and I'm
like I don't want to go to quiet sounds
like there's nothing going on it's the
most untouched one yeah exactly that's
the problem I want to [ __ ] do [ __ ] if
you ever are you just trying to like you
know let me know that you have a woman
and I don't because I do have a warranty
I would love to go to collide and she's
a white woman she's a beautiful blonde
woman so you're living my dream so when
you yeah no Kawaii is supposed to be
great for couples oh okay yeah because
it's I'm in a great relationship already
so why uh I wouldn't go to Kauai like me
personally I want to go to Kauai because
it's not it's not made for single people
yeah even Maui it's Maui's getting
better but it's not Maui's for retirees
that was nice Maui's nice nothing but
retirees not to rub it in but I got
engaged in Waikiki
doing a brag but I am I guess I am
rubbing in huh
we're very happy anyway the
um that's what stings the most is
happiness no they they think that they
think that the way that the scientist is
using these um old military systems in
order to see the weight the velocity
that it came in
probably an Antiquated method to to
determine its illness Interstellar
origin and speeding the precise angle
that it came through so that's the
critics who are saying that that's just
the old what's the new way well he's
just saying he's well there are new ways
but he's basically he's using this old
technology and they're saying that's too
old we should be using new [ __ ] and so
he's basically saying let's just go down
to the ocean floor and get the [ __ ] and
check it out and see why not but then
they're saying it's a waste of time and
money
he should meet with [ __ ] Steven
Spielberg man they got he's got that
thing oh James Cameron oh James Cameron
yeah yeah you know I I think Spielberg
is too busy with that he needs money
yeah so I think one of my conspiracy
theories is that they don't they're they
some of the day yeah some of the one
percent of the one percent yeah don't
want us to know if uh whether or not
aliens are real because you talk about
the lizard people yeah
some of those yeah yeah because if if if
aliens are real
it could throw a lot of societies out of
whack like parts of societies because
the average person might think oh I
think it'd be cool and then they just go
on their lives or trash religion too
which the Paradox
who's my god well Luxor would close oh
my God
I love Luxor because the elevator goes
sideways like that luxury
the light on right
it'd be tough man oh yeah
remember when uh Obama was on Joe Rogan
and it's like hey you saw like the whole
alien files or whatever like do you know
if there's aliens talk about Jay Leno he
was on Joe Rogan although I think he
went Obama's on Joe Rogan no he was
never on Joe Rogan who was there was a
president on Joe Rogan no there wasn't
that I wish I think you got to dream
about that I would love that oh but
there was a video clip of Obama talking
about Area 15 or 51 or yeah or something
like that he goes he he kind of did a
[ __ ] you know I had to kill you if I
tell you that kind of thing well Jimmy I
gave my kids uh I thought my kids I hate
the Halloween candy
laughs
[Music]